[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet après midi j'étais à l' usine mon
usine
j'ai regardé la france à travers la
vitre savez ce genre de vitres là je
peux comment ça s'appelle en sécurité
pour pâques un imbécile à il me balancer
un boulon dedans il nous la [ __ ] en
l'air
j'étais encore sous le choc
une scène très pénible avec les délégués
syndicaux
j'aurais dit voulait les clés vous les
voulez mais voilà mais si j'avais pas
dit poisson d'avril au dernier moment il
me les tickets
mon frère est entré avec son beau visage
buriné par le farniente
je dis comment ça va tu es vieux parce
qu'il s'était fait des ampoules aux
paupières
à force de dormir
regardez tous les deux la foule des
ouvriers qui s'écoulait de la sortie 830
personnes quand même plus 80 noir
et 120 femmes
au total un millier de personnes un
millier de salaire je sentais son odeur
de vétiver derrière moi il me dit de
savoir caverneuse bientôt plus personne
n'aura plus rien plus un lyon plus un
club de golf plus un van gogh rien ou
lamento la france ouf nous mène-t-il
pour moi j'ai mon dossier des impôts là
on me reproche mais chevaux de course
mais je suis navré un cheval de course
sap est moins qu'une secrétaire et nous
en parlions avec les autres la société
d'encouragement de la race chevaline
mais la race chevaline elle va
décourager mon yacht mon yacht 40 mètres
de long
quatre moteurs six marins
je vous passe l'urssaf mais vous savez
ce qu'on fait et mouiller août
on longe le bord du port de cannes parce
que mon épouse moeurs de peur
repas femme malade le climat social lui
donne de l'asthme
son seul dérivatif c'est de rajeunir
secret nuit et jour moralité en trois
ans à la radio ni d'une heure
on longe le bord ont fait des huit à
l'intérieur du port et on revient au
mouillage mais s'appuie stick qui ont
gènes qui ont gêne comme en fait foi que
j'entends ça pour quoi vous servez vous
d'un avion privé
parce que jean ni attendant on l'avion
et s'il me prenne dessus je mens pas non
non
j'étais obligé de dire à mon personnel
je ne peux pas vous garder je n'aime pas
la campagne on avait une paire d'émigrer
enfin bon équivalent fonds distincts
couple d'émigrés ou immigrés relâchez
pas con il faut dire ce sont comme dit
mon épouse on sait pas où ils vont d'où
ils viennent alors
l'immigré émirs et serviront même tahrir
même au demeurant des gens discrets ils
ont accepté un salaire pour deux
elle elle tient la maison elle fait la
cuisine lui il est logé dans son lit et
en échange on lui demande d'aidé un peu
au jardinage à la maçonnerie
l'entretien de la ferme
au gardiennage de nuit il conduit la
voiture
il a réparé quand elle est en panne
on a trois rugissent on occupe
ils coupent les arbres bon je leur fais
une salle de bain qu'est ce qu'ils me
foutent de d'un du charbon du charbon ma
mère et moi non plus c'est moi qui me
fais graf et par l'inspection du travail
ou les vous qui m est charmant budget la
salle de bains de la cad
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau ça
c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau
attendant la mise en place
mais ce qu'il fait je mens pas mais bon
donc là et tous les sans emploi je crée
votre jour un de mes livres y y et diane
de villandry se prend une épine dans une
pâte
voilà à 180 heures à ferrari pour foncer
chez le vétérinaire au croisement je
mens plafonne tracteur ben j'ai continué
j'avais rien voyage avait quand même mon
aileron arrière droit spécialement
accord aussi en italie par le couturier
giovanni tortelli qui carrosse mais
voiture et ma femme
l'aileron arraché c'est tout le monde
s'en fout mais derrière moi le paysan
bassin fracturé gendarmerie ambulanciers
brancardier deux motards pour le chemin
ils croisent les pompiers parce que le
tracteur s'était renversée incendies
dans les cultures
affolement à l'hôpital mais
saperlipopette je vais travailler toute
une région
je fais travailler toute une région
alors le 1 % voient la sécurité sociale
par exemple je suis allé voir mon
contrôleur des contributions et je dis
simplement combien gagnez vous combien
gagnez-vous il répond temps je lui dis
eh bien le 1 % comme le réclame sur mon
revenu représente cette fois votre
salaire
il est resté de marbre alors j'étais
obligé de dire ma femme je ne peux plus
te garder je ne peux plus l'état me
prends tous qu ils te prennent aussi qui
se chargent de toi ma poule jeu de
nationalise non partir changer d'horizon
demain de coutume racines partir loin
pour se faire naturaliser
il faut remplir un formulaire 1 pour
quel pays
optez vous deux pour quelles raisons
alors j'ai rempli et j'attends un monaco
2 pour lâcher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]